[Musique]
oui il devrait faire un mur
abbas ça dépend du mur du mur à mur
normal qu'après vos armures normale d'un
mur droit droit oui comme un étudiant
quel étudiant étudiant en droit à deux
cas l'auteur l'étudiante non le mur à
mur de ma taille
quand même mesurez-vous la hauteur d'un
petit mur bon alors ça dépend des
briques de leur largeur non leur hauteur
et la largeur d'une brique ça fait
combien environ trois fois la hauteur
oui alors j'ai intérêt à placer l'argent
mais pris dans son dos la hauteur ah oui
mais la largeur sera moins longue
et alors alors si la largeur et - ou
votre mur sera moins large on mettra
plus haut et c'est justement mais qui va
le faire ce mur mois ou avez vous appris
à faire les murs pendant mon service
militaire
béziers des mureaux régiment vannetais
1-1 quoi un mur et pourquoi faisiez-vous
un mur pour empêcher les autres de le
faire de faire quoi le mur ce portrait
clair c'est normal un mur se fait de
l'ombre
expliquez vous ça c'est très simple le
mur de la quinzaine étaient trop bas et
alors alors l'adjudant m'a demandé de
construire un autre dessus un autre quoi
un autre mur sur le mur trop bas pour
que les auteurs soient plus haute avant
alors en soit vous avez fait le mur pour
que les autres ne le fasse pas je ne
voulais pas le faire
ainsi voulais pas le faire nous avons
demandé d'en faire un autre qu'il ne
puisse pas le sentez vous combler non je
pense me rendent malade en tout cas
c'est pas facile d'élever un mur c'est
plus facile que d'élever une
protestation
pourquoi il veut une protestation non
j'ai dit il va une protestation comme
aujourd'hui il veut un caïman vous avez
un caïman pays à ramener du japon il
parle japonais lui non mais moi oui ou
par les japonais je suis en train
d'apprendre
il varie c'est plus facile que chinois
tout ça c'est des honda de mandat d'un
an des on-dit ique visite à votre cayman
hallegatte aux alligators non
obligatoire ali gâteau à oui ça veut
dire les gâteaux merci vous dit merci
autres km oui il doit être content mais
il remue la queue quand il est content
non pourquoi est ce qu un caïman ce
n'est pas un chien vous le savez vous
ils aiment par dessus
avant ils mangent du poisson des fruits
des bananes ont des murs alors en
parlant de murs qu'est ce que je disais
oui mais tu sais que t'es pas facile
d'être un mur c'est exact mais prenez le
camp des lambert par exemple qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait les landais bien ils ont
essayé d'élever un mur est alors alors
leurs murs et un malaise il est grossier
j étais trop mûr pour son âge pour se
faire une raison vous avez visité
jérusalem b embarque en barque
c'était inondées à cause de la pluie non
trop demande au mur des lamentations
enfin vrai que c'est un troll autre
chose que le mur de berlin avant l'avait
visitée ne visite pas un mur on le
regarde
rio vendra en faisant attention quand on
grass pourquoi parce que les murs ont
des oreilles c'est juste bon alors
qu'est ce que je savais que mon mur mais
c'est pourquoi faire ça c'est pour ne
plus voir les gens qui m'entourent
si vous en fait je ne supporte plus
comment ça se fait ça j'ai eu une mise
en trope misanthrope misanthrope
alors si vous êtes misanthrope ne faites
pas votre mur en briques alors en quoi
en pierre meulière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]